[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we are
canceling the dreaded the stupid
the pointless
pay it forward drive through chains now
if you aren't familiar with this
thoroughly first world phenomenon here's
a story about the latest one to pop up
from cnn
uh there's a bunch of stories about this
let yesterday but this the cnn says what
started as a random act of kindness from
one man paying the paying for the car
behind him in a dairy queen drive-thru
resulted in over 900 cars also taking
part in the pay it forward chain at a
drive-through in brainerd minnesota over
100 miles north of minneapolis people
stepped up in a small way to show one
another that they care tina jensen the
store manager one of the two dairy
queens in town told cnn a man came by
the drive-through window on thursday and
asked if he could pay for his meal and
for the car behind him jensen told her
cashier this tends to happen once in a
while but at most it lasts for 15 or 20
cars cars and fizzles out this time the
chain continued for two and a half days
with over 900 cars participating raking
in ten thousand dollars in sales when
the next customer came to the fast food
chains window jensen explained what the
man in front of them had done and the
act of kindness continued to multiply
jensen said there's all different types
of ways to help people i think this
touched a lot of people that we didn't
even know it touched deeper than we know
and you don't know what's going on in a
person's life when the chain closed for
the for the night on thursday one car
left ten dollars to begin the chain back
up on friday morning and then the same
thing happened on friday night and it
began on saturday morning okay
so that's how it works somebody pays for
the meal of the person behind them in
line then that person pays for the
person behind them and on and on it goes
but do you know who the real hero in
this story is
not the first person to pay for the next
person no the real hero is whoever broke
the chain and simply accepted the
charity from the person in front and
drove away
leaving the person behind them to pay
for their own damned fudge sundae
it all all of the people in between the
first guy who may have been well
intentioned but should have thought more
about the consequences of his actions
and the last guy who had the courage to
end the whole charade everybody else
these were just sheep they weren't
performing acts of kindness this wasn't
charity they did it because they were
too embarrassed and felt too much social
pressure not to do it
if it's charity at all it's coerced
charity and not for a meaningful cause
either the people in the drive-thru line
have disposable income that they were
already planning to spend on the same
kind of junk that you're buying they
don't need your money
really this kind of charity if it is
charity at all again is similar to the
sort of charity that you perform
when you're checking out at the grocery
store and the cashier asks if you want
to round up and donate your change to
you know orphaned sea otters or whatever
the only reason you say yes is because
you'd feel like a cheap ass refusing to
give your 27 cents to the sea otters
it's not something that comes from the
kindness of your heart
if you wanted to help the sea otters on
your own time you would right now all
you want to do is pay for your carton of
eggs and your package of paper towels
and leave the grocery store is taking
advantage of your sense of shame
to build another few cents out of you
another few cents of which they will
surely take a cut by the way
but while the grocery store charity
gambit is a calculated ploy to take
advantage of people who don't have the
spine to say no the pay it forward chain
is more of a case of collective insanity
everyone is doing it but nobody knows
why
if you want to understand how crazy it
is
imagine how it would come across if you
took
you know take take the fast food and the
cars out of the equation okay now
imagine you're standing in a long line
of people
uh waiting for something and the guy in
front turns to you
gives you five dollars out of his wallet
and then suggests that you turn around
and give the person behind you some
money out of your wallet and on and on
and on
now you're all just passing money
backwards for absolutely no reason
nobody wants to be doing it or knows why
they're doing it but it continues until
some free thinker accepts the cash from
the person in front and says hey thanks
for the money puts it in their pocket
and gives nothing to the person behind
that person again is the admirable
character in this strange saga
now if i sound like i'm speaking from a
place of personal trauma when i talk
about this that's because i am
i used to live near a starbucks where
this would happen frequently
i was duped by it i'm ashamed to admit
one time and one time only i pulled up
to the window to pay for my one single
coffee for 265
and the girl at the window told me that
the bill had been paid by the guy in
front
then she informed me that they were
doing this pay it forward thing where
each person pays for the one behind and
she asked me if i wanted to participate
and told me that you know they kept the
chain going for 50 cars so far or
however many it was
so i said
uh yeah okay
sure
and then she said okay that'll be 43.50
i had just traded in my two dollar
coffee for a whole suv load of lattes
and frappuccinos and god only knows what
else
it was the worst deal in history as
trump might have said if you'd saw it
so i drove away
broken
confused
my coffee now tinged with a taste of
betrayal
and i resolved then to never allow
myself to be shamed into empty gestures
of pointless charity and from then on
whenever someone in front paid for my
drink i said oh great
i accepted the free coffee drove away
with no remorse
in fact proud that i had saved others
from this farce
and even and you know when the cashier
asks me now about the sea otters i say
no thank you i don't want to help him
in fact the sea otters can go to hell
and i walk away feeling fine
though wondering if i was a little
harsher towards the sea otters than
necessary
anyway this is why the pay it forward
drive-through lines are canceled
forever and always
by the way i must also acknowledge my
own debt for the cancellation today this
was inspired by amanda prestigiacomo a
writer for the daily wire who spoke out
against this yesterday the paid forward
lines on twitter got me thinking about
this so she is the opposite of canceled
but everybody else in that 900 person
chain in minnesota
is
unfortunately
cancelled have you noticed that big tech
companies today are masquerading as
privacy companies big tech literally
feeds on your information like parasites
sure maybe they'll release a feature now
and then that does some good but
collecting and selling off your data is
big tech's that's their mo it's in their
nature they can't stop themselves from
looking at what you do online to protect
myself then against big tech's prying
eyes i use expressvpn when you use
expressvpn on your computer or front
you're hiding your unique ip address
websites can't use that address to find
out your real location or track what you
do online expressvpn encrypts and
reroutes 100 of your online activities
so your internet provider wi-fi
administrator and uh hackers can't see
it at all and expressvpn is incredibly
easy to use it takes just one click to
protect all of your devices one
expressvpn subscription covers up up to
five devices at the same time so you can
protect your entire family at the same
time that's why expressvpn is rated
number one by cnet wired tech radar and
countless others get the vpn that i
trust to protect my online privacy from
big bad tech visit expressvpn.com walsh
and you could get an extra three months
free on a one year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh expressvpn.com walsh to learn more
so today we're going to cancel this man
ryan dorsey and all his kind all his ilk
he's a baltimore city council mayor uh
member i should say i've been i don't
mean that kind that's not the kind i'm
referring to um though sure we can
cancel the baltimore city council i
guess why not they really haven't been
doing much good recently and by recently
i mean for the past i don't know five
decades or so but that's not the point
today
the point is this tweet from dorsey um
and there's a picture there of a fedex
truck and a bike lane in the city and it
says quote hey fedex i told your driver
here to get out of the bike lane he was
obstructing which i happened to be
biking in his response was get a car
now needless to say this fedex driver is
awesome
ryan dorsey on the other hand is the
lamest dork this side of justin trudeau
not only is he riding a bike
and bitching at a delivery guy
but after the delivery guy verbally
backhands him he posts his own
humiliation on social media thinking
he'll get sympathy from the public
rather than the relentless mockery and
scorn he deserves quick tip here even
for people who aren't lame dorks
when the internet has to choose between
sympathy or scorn
it will always choose scored always
so keep that in mind or learn it the
hard way as ryan dorsey has
but
this behavior is what i would expect
from dorsey given that he is a cyclist
cyclists and i mean those who ride bikes
on the street
and you know streets
those things where cars go
those kinds of cyclists are a cursed
breed
they are among the worst people on earth
the absolute dregs of humanity
no one no offense intended
every time i'm driving down a busy
street
and traffic is backed up for miles
because everyone has to navigate around
some weirdo on a bike i am perplexed
anew
how is this even legal i think to myself
why are we allowing people to ride their
bikes on roads where cars are supposed
to go
now i get that you want to exercise
that's fine
but why are you exercising in the damned
street during rush hour
i like to exercise too
i'm not going to set up a bench press on
the freeway i'm not going to take an ab
roller down to the nearest intersection
hey give me a minute i got three more
sets all right hold on
why why won't i do that because i'm not
a lunatic
and i care about other people
sort of
at least i'm not going to go out of my
way to make their commute longer and
more stressful than it already is i'm
not going to do that cyclists do that
now what gets me about the bike riders
is their sense of entitlement it's not
just that they have the audacity to play
with their toy in the street it's that
they they get angry at you for being
there they act like you are
inconveniencing them
they act like you just jumped on the
same elliptical that they were using at
the gym
but the street is not your elliptical
it's a street
if you want an elliptical
go use an elliptical
and if you want to play with your bike
go to a park or a bike trail in the
woods
or maybe daddy can take you down to the
tennis courts near the playground so you
can ride your big wheel around maybe
that or better yet ditch the bike and be
an adult
find a hobby that isn't as likely to
make you a victim of vehicular
manslaughter
just a thought
now i know i'll be told that some people
use bikes as transportation not as toys
or exercise equipment fine
but the street
is for a certain type of transportation
vehicle transportation
if you can use your bike as
transportation on the street then why
can't i use a pogo stick why can't i
pogo down to work
maybe the city will be maybe the city
can build me a pogo lane
just for me
you know why can't i take this office
chair right here it's got wheels i just
roll it down the
highway why can't i go out to 10th
avenue and do cartwheels for five blocks
i'm just it's just transportation
hey this is how i get to work all right
i cartwheel to work
we all have our methods
why not because again that would be
insane
and the road isn't made for it the road
in fact is made so that five thousand
pounds hunk five thousand pound hunks of
metal can fly down them at high speeds
that's what it's there for
it's not made so that middle-aged
vegetarians and spandex shorts can burn
off some calories on the way to work
commuting is not a time for burning
calories anyway that's the other
annoying thing
the rest of us are jamming donuts into
our fat faces while we sit in traffic
and stew in our own body fat and misery
and you're riding by all brisk and
healthy and happy it's irritating
especially around thanksgiving
and it's grotesque
and it's dangerous
and it's an inconvenience to me
so
cyclists are cancelled
take an uber next time